this video is sponsored by endl
what would you do if you are really
really smart like a super genius would
you turn to altruism would you try and
solve world hunger or poverty maybe you
just try and get rich maybe play the
stock market and become a billionaire
maybe you'd create a hit app that solves
a real problem and gets you rich in the
process maybe you try and crack the
secrets of the universe or perhaps just
try and solve all your own problems in
your own life the thing is though the
traditional methods that we use to try
and improve our intelligence and our
brain function aren't going to get you
there not brain training not traditional
meditation for that we need something
else something that i call big idea
meditation and yes i'm really sick hence
the voice
see the thing with traditional
meditation and brain training is it's
all about enhancing focus or being
mindful and living in the now in fact we
tend to demonize anything along the
lines of daydreaming or mind wandering
of course being very focused and having
great math skills and quick thinking is
all very useful if you're doing maths or
if you're in a conversation we need to
be witty however this isn't the kind of
thinking that leads to breakthroughs or
real big changes in your life just being
more focused isn't going to suddenly
make your life a whole lot better and in
fact what we tend to now think of as
genius
actually has more to do with creativity
and novel thinking people like einstein
were pretty sure their genius is not
because of their score on an iq test but
because he changed the way we think
about physics and the universe this
comes from a different type of thinking
altogether
so in most forms of meditation often
described as directive meditation the
aim is to empty your mind of thoughts or
to focus on just one thing like a mantra
or your breathing and like i say this is
fantastic for improving concentration
and focus which can also improve your
working memory make the whole world seem
richer so i'm not saying this isn't
useful however what i'm talking about
this big idea meditation is more about
allowing yourself to daydream and to let
your mind wonder but doing it in a
slightly structured way so that you can
explore interesting ideas that might be
beneficial or just fascinating to you so
for example you might ruminate on what
you think started the universe or maybe
you might think how would i write the
next james bond movie for example this
is going to practice deep and creative
thinking and by practicing deep and
creative thinking you'll get better at
deep and creative thinking and then when
you have a problem that you need to
approach or when you want to come up
with a novel idea you'll find it much
easier to do so and you might just find
that in the process you stumble upon
something really amazing
put it this way the bioneer wouldn't
exist if i hadn't spent a lot of time
with big idea thinking or big idea
meditation likewise when i was much
younger i used this technique to come up
with an app that turned out to be highly
successful on the play store that ended
up getting over 10 000 paid downloads
which wasn't life-changing but at the
time for someone who has just moved to
london it was pretty life-changing for
me
whether you're trying to meditate or
just trying to focus something that
could be really useful is the right
atmosphere the right to backing track or
soundscape and that's where today's
sponsor endl comes in so endless an app
that creates soundscapes for you
designed to help you relax and stay calm
or to focus or to sleep the different
soundscapes depending on your specific
requirements i personally have used
endle in the past long before they
sponsored this channel i used endl to
help me focus on my work and according
to brain imaging it looks like endl can
help you to get into a productive and
focused state more quickly than your
spotify playlist this makes a lot of
sense because endless provides that
backing noise that helps you to tune in
and feel at ease but without the
distractions the familiar lyrics or the
change of track that you're familiar
with when you use something like spotify
i've also used endle to help me sleep
and it can be very relaxing they've just
released a new soundscape by james blake
called wind down which is perfect for
chilling out in the evening getting
ready for bed there's a bunch of these
different soundscapes from different
artists with different themes which is
really cool and a lot of the scenarios
are ai based meaning they can react to
things like the time of day the weather
etc to get you into the perfect mood for
the current situation it has really cool
visualizations it works on a bunch of
devices so i highly recommend endl so if
you need help to increase your focus
then the first 100 people to download
endl at the link below will get a free
week of audio experiences
of course i'm far from the first person
to recommend the benefits of deep
thinking and rumination cal newport
author of deep work he recommended
something he called productive
meditation where you would simply
dedicate your mind to solving a
particular problem for a certain amount
of time this tended to be more in the
context of business or a creative
challenge but of course it can apply to
anything when i was younger i always
used to think that any problem i had i
just think about it overnight and in the
morning i'd normally be able to do at
least something about it if not solve
the problem at least improve the
situation the likes of nikola tesla and
carl young used to go for inspiration
walks where they go for a long walk and
just let their minds wander and this led
to some of their greatest breakthroughs
meditation doesn't have to be directive
another example of a non-directive form
of meditation is akam meditation where
you just let your mind wander let your
mind drift and here there's absolutely
no structure or attempt to control you
just let it go where it goes and this
has been shown to have some very close
similarities to dreaming
so there is a lot of support for this
idea but on the whole we somewhat
demonized the whole concept of mind
wandering we're so focused on being in
the now and not living in the past or
not dreaming about the future that we
tell people to get out of their heads
and we act as though ever not being
mindful is a bad thing however great
breakthroughs come when you let your
mind wander and there's actually lots of
evidence now to support the health
benefits of doing just that all i'm
doing that's slightly different is i
tend to pick myself a big question
something that's inherently abstract and
huge and then ruminate on that i often
come back to the same questions things
that i find interesting and just
practice my problem-solving skills
i say there is now actually evidence
that mind-wandering and deep thought are
really healthy and good for your brain
the default mode network is the
specific pattern of brain areas that
activate when you're deep in thought
it's also called the task negative
network it's basically when you're not
putting your brain towards some kind of
complex task but just letting it wonder
mind wandering activates the default
mode network it's mainly what it's for
but at the same time we now know that
activation in the default mode network
correlates with not only creativity and
creative problem solving but also with
fluid intelligence so unsurprisingly
people who are better at thinking deeply
have more connectivity and activation in
this area are better at coming up with
creative solutions to problems now this
is a coveration not causation but we can
probably assume that if you spend time
practicing using your default mode
network you're going to get better at
using it in the same study it was also
shown that deep thinking and mind
wandering could increase connectivity
between the default mode network and the
fronto parietal control network so the
latter being a network that's involved
in goal setting and goal oriented
thinking so in other words you're
improving your ability potentially to
think deeply and then to come up with a
solution or a goal that you can actually
act on to actually create concrete steps
from that thought another study and i
will link to all this study somewhere
down below has shown that simply
thinking about long-term goals and
planning behavior can actually improve
your likelihood of actually achieving
your goals and following through those
plans so again if you're going to be
thinking deeply about the things you
want to achieve and what you want to be
then it stands to reason that this might
help you to actually achieve and be
those things it's also just really fun
you know just deep thinking it's a great
way to pass the time and if you're
someone uses meditation as a kind of
therapy to escape dark thoughts i mean
that's one of the reasons people often
warn against deep thinking and mind
wondering because people tend to turn
their thoughts towards dark things but
if you can just escape your reality for
a moment and imagine what it'll be like
if you could jump super high into the
air this can be a great way of coping
with difficult times and again another
study has actually shown that when given
the marshmallow task you know the one
where you have to avoid eating the
marshmallows now to get more in the
future um people who are capable of mind
wondering who do this frequently are
actually better at resisting that
temptation because they think they can
escape into their thoughts to get away
from the temptation how do we go about
doing it if we want to get some of these
benefits one researcher who's really
interested in mind wandering and
daydreaming is erin westgate and she
found that actually people are very bad
at mind wandering and daydreaming she
found that people would either not think
about anything or they think about
boring things like writing tasks or they
might even ruminate on negative subjects
which is one of the reasons people have
sometimes warned against deep thinking
and encourage us to be in the now but
daydreaming can be really fun it can be
meaningful it can be productive so what
she recommends is giving people prompts
that can help them to direct that
thinking and this way you're getting the
benefits the creative benefits
potentially of dreaming but where you
have the ability to choose precisely
what you're going to focus on so write
yourself down some questions whether
that's what would i do if i were
president or prime minister or how would
i go about addressing issues with
poverty or what can i do next week next
month next year that's going to help me
earn more money or be happier or what
fun things could i do with my family
anything like that deep thinking
creative thinking try and solve some
deep problems
putting aside some time each week to do
this in the same way that you might
practice other forms of meditation and i
recommend combining this with other
forms of meditation because no type of
brain state is
optimal you want to be able to switch
between them all and this is where it's
really important to be able to not only
be very focused but also to let your
mind wander and be creative it's just
like physical fitness just like i don't
think you should become super strong at
the expense of all cardio i likewise
don't think you should focus on just one
aspect of cognitive performance i think
you should focus on them all
this in my opinion is more how you go
about having a limitless type experience
where you can actually change your life
by thinking deeply
and i think if more people did this then
we'd have some more interesting ideas in
the world
[Music]
hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around that
helped me out immensely let me know in
the comments down below whether you
meditate will you now be actively
integrating daydreaming and mind
wandering into your routine into your
cognitive training plan if you like this
kind of training that looks not only at
physical performance not only aesthetics
but also even brain function then you'll
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional training 2.0 the
protein performance system that comes
with a massive 80 plus page ebook which
dives into physical and mental
performance and it also comes with over
two hours of video tutorials showing you
how to do the workouts there's a large
focus in there on brain training and
cognitive performance including a brain
training routine and a guided meditation
and i've just added to the program a
series of prompts to help you get
started with big idea meditation ideas
for things that you can think about that
allow you to explore that kind of deep
thinking
if you've already bought super
functional training 2.0 then it's there
right now it'll be in the extra
materials right at the bottom so head on
over there and check it out if you
haven't then you'll get it if you do
decide to make a purchase
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys i massively
appreciate it subscribe if you want to
see more like this and hit the bell
button if you want to be notified of
future uploads
and of course i'll see you next time
bye for now